[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
SVD and one of the most important things
you need to know when you're using the
singular value decomposition for
dimensionality reduction of a data
matrix X is how your data is aligned
okay so in that example of eigenfaces
where we take each column of X is a
picture of a human face that's been
reshaped into a column vector it was
critical that all of those images were
cropped and aligned so that the same
pixels the same rows of ax meant the
same thing from image to image so that
image 1 this pixel it means an eye pixel
even an image 2 and 3 and fourths the
same meaning across all of the pixels
because the SVD is based on correlations
of the columns and of the rows and so if
I take the dot product of two columns
and the mouth is over here in one image
and over here in another then the dot
product doesn't really mean anything
then closeness of those two vectors
doesn't mean anything and so oftentimes
we're going to use this SVD for
dimensionality reduction in image
classification or image compression and
in that case you really do need to have
some kind of alignment of your data
features even more importantly when you
have when you're using this for physics
modeling like maybe this is data from a
simulation of a physical system so
columns are the state of a physical
system as they evolve in time maybe I
have a traveling wave or a rotating wave
or something like that the SVD is really
going to struggle to find a low-rank
representation of a traveling or
rotating structure because it's not
aligned in terms of the rows and the
columns of the data matrix okay and so
the examples that I have here are cooked
up to walk you through kind of what can
go wrong if you have a low rank matrix
and you rotate it or translate it or
something like that okay and again all
this code is at databook u-dub comm this
is the MATLAB version and so the first
code what I'm going to do is essentially
just cook up a large example
of two data matrices this is literally
just a data matrix that has zeros and
ones so black and white
this one has low rank structure so if I
take the SVD of this matrix it is almost
entirely characterized by one singular
value one extremely energetic singular
value and everything else is below the
the noise floor kind of machine
precision noise because this data is
aligned there is essentially one eigen
row and one eigen column that describe
that you can multiply together to make
this entire matrix okay essentially you
would you would literally just multiply
you know that that column by that row
and what you would get out would be this
matrix okay so it's really a 1 Rank 1
matrix
you know zeros and ones with rank 1 but
if you even rotate this a little bit if
you rotate this a little bit then the
the same kind of row and column
information from before gets destroyed
so that's what we're seeing over here on
the right is just a slightly rotated
version of this matrix where now you can
see that you actually have a very very
high rank effective SVD so when you look
at the singular values these are the the
logs of the diagonal elements of Sigma
these singular values take a long time
to decay it's over 200 rank system 250
degrees of freedom are needed to add up
to equal this matrix
even though as humans we know that
nothing really changed this is still a
rank 1 object in a rotated frame but the
SVD can't figure that out unless you
align that data into a frame where
everything kind of clicks into place
ok and it's you can make kind of a nice
visualization out of this where you just
rotate through increasingly large angles
here so this is another code in the book
where you basically take that same idea
and you just rotate it more and more and
more and what you can see in rainbow
colors here so as you go from yeah
- orange - blue - bright blue the rank
just gets worse and worse and worse as
you take this thing out of alignment in
in rows and column spaces so again the
SVD is not magic it's based entirely on
correlations between the columns of X
and and each other and the rows of X and
each other and so if you take something
low rank and kind of rotate it so that
those that alignment disappears in row
and column space you're gonna get this
rank explosion and so this is really
important if you have data similarly if
I took data of a square moving across
the screen so I had a movie of a square
moving across a screen or if my data had
you know something moving across the
columns even if it was the same object
the SVD would still give you a very high
rank system because it doesn't know
about translational invariance or
rotational invariance even though as
humans were really good at detecting
these things and recognizing that these
are all just squares at different
rotation angles okay so something to be
aware of when you use the SVD it can be
really really useful if rows and columns
mean the same thing from data set to
data set so as a kind of a counter
example of how what can go wrong if we
go back to that ovarian cancer data set
where we had 216 people and something
like 4,000 genetic markers that's a
great example of the data being aligned
because it was the same genetic marker
column 500 was the same genetic marker
across all of the people and column 501
was the same other genetic marker and so
the data was somehow aligned so that you
know columns meant the same thing across
all of the patients all of the people
okay so this is a cautionary tale you
have to be careful when doing the SVD
and make sure that your data is kind of
aligned and cropped and and organized so
that you expect that there to be there
there will be these kind of row wise and
column wise correlations okay thank you